it's a Thursday tradition in these parts
show me something the divisional round
coming up for games that will determine
the NFL's final four Chris let's do it
right now she'll be something entering
the four games that are coming up
Saturday and Sunday
there's always rigged coin toss you call
it let's get it rigged Kristen make sure
you punch in tails cuz you know that's
never fails let's go you don't know for
sure yeah I know your pick I'm going I'm
going
oh you wrote a CH in there aw that's my
name okay I'm gonna go with Andy tell me
who you wrote or picking I'm gonna go
with Andy Reid for the show me something
draft and you read we know what kind of
coach he is I mean he's been phenomenal
brought his Philadelphia Eagles to the
Superbowl but of course has never won a
Super Bowl and this is a big moment for
him Andy Reid we know about the Kansas
City Chiefs and their playoff struggles
especially at home you got Patrick
mahomes who's gonna be the NFL MVP okay
and you've you are the master of the bye
week coming back and you know dispelling
all those issues we talked about a bye
week every year Andy Reid's team's
success rate after a week off during a
regular season has been phenomenal
unfortunately it hasn't been that great
always when he's the coach or the hitter
in the playoffs and he's got a bye week
this week so I just want to say Andy
Reid show me something as far as having
your team ready to play some new
offensive looks that defenses haven't
prepared for and concepts and go out
there and let it rip against the
Indianapolis Colts and win a game that
you should win I know this is dangerous
but they are at home they are the number
one seed and they got the best
quarterback on the field and some good
pass rushers to go with it so I start
with Andy Reid there and show me
something and show me something you got
something special in the game plan to
give your team an advantage this week
no playoff wins at home for the Chiefs
since 1993 when they had Green cement on
a playing surface at era
and it's been a long road and they've
lost plenty of home playoff games along
the way this is hardly their first home
playoff game in 25 years they've had one
seeds they've had home playoff games
yeah had one last year against the
Titans and they lost it the wild-card
round so that's not a bad choice by you
but I thought you were gonna go for the
Saturday night primetime game because
the guy who is at the center of the
storm for the LA Rams if this team is
going to make a playoff run if they're
gonna win a playoff game last year they
lost to the Atlanta Falcons and Matt
Ryan quarterback driven league and the
quarterback of the Rams starting with
that game against the Bears in December
it was cold it was windy Jared Goff all
of a sudden didn't look all that good
and there are more and more questions
about whether or not he's simply a I
hate to say it system quarterback Jared
Goff show us you're not a system
quarterback show us you can solve a very
difficult Cowboys defense stand-in there
like Nick Foles doesn't take that big
hit just so you can hold the ball an
extra split second longer to let your
guy get open or throw him open
that's what golf needs to do if the rams
want to avoid two consecutive one and
outs with home playoff losses in the
Coliseum yeah I mean he was he was
certainly I was thinking about taking
him as the number one pick so you you
would have been right if I had gone
there yeah there's I mean you said it
last year the wild-card game against the
Atlanta Falcons he did not play well I
mean he was really one of the biggest
reasons they lost they left a lot of
yards and completions out on the field
and he wasn't on his a-game
you know he's won some big games but he
certainly hasn't been really really
sharp in some big games either you know
hey the Saints game that was awesome
this year right but he did throw a like
one pick in kind of a big moment you
know we course at the Bears game the
Eagles game shortly after that those are
playoff caliber teams that we go it
wasn't as good as we'd like so I get you
there it's not a bad pick I'm actually
gonna stay in the same football game and
I like to spread it around but I just
got to make this pick and my show me
something there's a Rams d-line hey Rams
d-line I mean you got the Dallas Cowboys
coming into town one of the biggest
baddest old lines in the sport and they
never make they never like try to hide
the fact that they're coming into town
to run downhill and physically
each year but on the defensive line and
Ramsey line
you've been 23rd in football against the
rush this year man there's a lot of cash
on that D line for you guys to be 23rd
in football against the rush
Suh Donald Dante Fowler
okay Michael brokers I'm saying you know
who's got incoming he was coming into
town you've had a week to prepare a week
off you got to show me something that
you can stop this Dallas run game and
make dak Prescott and that pass game
beat you which would become very iffy if
that became the case so I say Erin
Donald sue those guys they got to show
me something this week that they can
improve that run defense if they want to
win the football game and I think Sue's
the key because the Bears gave everyone
the blueprint for dealing with the Rams
defensive line you double-team Erin
Donald everybody did that down the
stretch except the Cardinals we gave up
three sacks to the guy focus on Donald
and forced the others to step up sue
hasn't stepped up now maybe he will in
the postseason but we're talking about a
very good Cowboys offensive line as well
and he won't be able to step up maybe
the only stepping he'll be doing is on
someone at some point after a play which
isn't an unfair shot we've seen it
before it's well documented and I think
I think we can see a frustration level
from sue if if he can't wreak havoc if
they are neutral on something around
right I agree with you that and I would
have picked sue because I always prefer
more narrow I'm surprised you didn't say
the entire Rams organization including
their fans and including all residents
of Southern California which is also I I
was going to say Rams fans show up at
the Coliseum and support these guys
instead of Cowboys fans but it might be
too late for that
so I agree with you Rams defensive line
but specifically in Dhamma can sue all
right let's stay in LA but not for that
game a team that is nine and oh outside
of Los Angeles this year going into a
place where Tom Brady is eight and oh
this season and seven and OH all-time
wherever they have played against
Phillip Rivers Rivers has never beaten
Brady in his career his one win again
against the Patriots game in 2008 when
Brady was out with a torn ACL this is
Phillip Rivers chance this is his time
this is the opportunity to right all the
wrongs of his career over the past
decade and to beat Tom Brady
his own game and come within one game of
a Super Bowl berth I'm not sure he can
do it but he's the guy that's got to
step up and show us something as he
tries with possibly the best team he's
ever had around him to get to the Super
Bowl yeah there's no doubt about that I
mean this is a huge game from and you
know I'll say this to Mike you know the
the Chargers offense it's been
underwhelming as of late I am a little
concerned in this matchup
you know I don't think Philip Rivers
towards the end of the season was
playing his best football I thought his
arm looked a little tired
I think the receivers have looked a
little tired as well and just in my
opinion the through evaluating film I
don't see the separation I used to and
you know I think people have gotten a
little bit of a feel for their offense
and we know the run game hasn't been
where it needs to be so I mean I was
going to pick Phillip Rivers next I'm
kind of pissed pissed you took it
because I do think it's a big moment for
him and I do think they're gonna have to
throw the football and beat this very
good Patriots secondary that way so so
that's where I would say good job by you
man him kids coast-to-coast his uncle
Chris expands your vocabulary while
you're eating your post toast oh well if
they think that's a bad word then then
they don't want to see me in person okay
stop that's for sure
yes okay go ahead III think I know I
don't I know you don't want me to do
this but gosh uh I think I'm gonna like
you to do it cuz I don't give you a hard
time I know I'm going with a whole unit
I want to say Saints defense okay I just
you know hey the Saints defense has been
you know this remarkable turnaround
through it from the start of the year to
now they really have fixed so many
things and really have been playing
awesome football they were really the
strength of the New Orleans Saints down
the stretch this Eagles defense has been
playing very good lately but the big
point is this this is the Saints you're
at home in the Superdome you got Nick
Foles and the Philadelphia magic Eagles
coming into town who have found their
magic from last year you know you're
supposed to dot not dominate this
football team but certainly win this
football game and and the magic that
we've heard about Nick Foles you're the
number one seed you're clearly the best
team in football all
around but I say hey we always talk
about the Saints in the offense and I
look at this one going hey I don't know
if you can necessarily depend on the
offense to put up 48 like last time and
the way the Eagles defenses of the plan
I don't know if you can expect them to
put up more than 28 in this football
game I think it's going to be tough
sledding and because of that that's why
I say the Saints defense has got to show
me something here because they are gonna
have to get pressure on Nick Foles with
just the front for they got to stop
hurts and Geoffrey who are his go-to
guys he puts the ball up in all these
great spots to where they can get it and
nobody else they better have some new
looks for this Philadelphia Eagles
offense as compared to last time around
because you know the Eagles are going to
adjust but this is a game where I look
at and go hey there's no guarantee here
your offense is gonna light up the
scoreboard this is a different thing
here you're gonna have to slow down the
foals magic and the Doug Peterson
playoff magic that's why I go Saints my
biggest concern for the Saints when
Eagles walk into the Superdome they see
a team that they beat 48 to 70 s largest
victory margin all season long and how
do you forget that that's the team that
you manhandled and how do you react if
they hit you in the mouth
early on because they're there live it
up they're ready to go they just beat
the Bears they're confident you're the
one that has had two weeks off as a
practical matter because week 17 was
irrelevant Drew Brees didn't play sure
and and I wonder how you get the Saints
to focus on beating the Eagles and the
story came out yesterday that one of the
things Sean Payton did he brought in
$200,000 plus in cash plus the Lombardi
Trophy I heard the same thing happened
back in 2009 when they ended up winning
the Superbowl you don't think about the
Eagles at that point it's a nameless
faceless low goalless opponent that is
just the team that is in your way as you
try to get that 200 grand and you try to
get that Super Bowl trophy and the ring
that goes along with it that may be the
difference for the Saints they need
something otherwise they're going to be
in real trouble with the Eagles yes they
definitely are alright my last one
icon no I wanted to see if you wanted
that anything but if you're just gonna
say yes they are I'll continue yes
Patriots tight end Rob Gronkowski a guy
that we have been
saying some fairly candid things about
all season long it seems like physically
he's not there maybe emotionally he's
not there maybe he's getting ready to
retire and walk away this is his chance
to step up and remind everyone who he is
he just doesn't still look the part he
can play the part is he physically
capable of doing it we'll find out but
if the Patriots are gonna beat the
charges one of the things they need is
contributions from Gronk and it can't be
two catches for twenty yards it needs to
be Gronk doing Gronk things and if he
can't do it now with a championship
within reach maybe it is time for Gronk
to walk away and if he isn't ready to
walk away maybe it's time for the
Patriots to cut the cord we know they'd
like to do it one you're too early Chris
instead of one year too late yeah that's
right and then well I mean we know they
do they tried to do it last year a
little bit Gronk is certainly yes going
to have to play better football I think
that's a very real factor in this
football game the Patriots of course
their offense is better than the
Baltimore Ravens it's more diverse they
want to run the ball just like the
Ravens do they just do it a different
way the difference between them and the
Ravens though is the Patriots have nine
million play-action passes off their
runs and I think that's where Gronkowski
can certainly become effective fake the
run those safeties and linebackers fly
up into the line of scrimmage Gronkowski
gets behind you the matchup and within
the matchup there two when they play
man-to-man
Derwin James has the type of guy that
can shut down a Rob Gronkowski he's got
the skillset that'll be fun to watch all
right quick recap Chris's pick show me
something Andy Reed the Rams defensive
line in the entire New Orleans Saints
defense
I've got Jared Goff Phillip Rivers Rob
Gronkowski I win about one guy would ya
did show me something one four I focus
on one at a time when we return we're
gonna focus on two the two remaining
vacancies bengals dolphins what happens
next PFT live back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports